foreign
equipment editors blog for October 16
2012.
in the next week or so you'll be
receiving the October November issue of
farm equipment magazine that features
the 2013 dealer Outlook and Trends
report
this is based on the survey of North
American dealers we conduct annually
just prior to the farm progress show in
Boone Iowa in early September I had the
opportunity to travel for a day with
some investment fund managers visiting
farm equipment dealers in Iowa
at some point during one of the meetings
someone asked me what I thought about
equipment sales in the year ahead
based on my conversations with dealers
at the time I told them I thought sales
might be down as much as 10 percent
several times throughout the rest of
that day I was asked why I thought sales
might decline in 2013. I told them that
dealers didn't seem to be as confident
this year as they were last year at this
time and I pointed out that my comments
at that time were based solely on
empirical data it it had become obvious
to me that the impact of the widespread
drought of 2012 and the farmer's
reaction to it were the biggest unknowns
going into the new selling season
now the results of the annual survey add
more Credence to those comments last
year at this time 55.3 percent of
dealers surveyed forecast new equipment
sales would rise by two percent or more
this year that percentage fell to 42.6
percent the percentage of dealers who
believe sales would decline by two
percent or more a year ago was only 11.5
percent versus 26.4 percent this year
but there were other indications from
this year's survey that showed that
dealers are not nearly as confident as
they were a year ago
one was the number of pre-sales this
year versus last year according to our
most recent survey almost identical
percentages of dealers say their early
orders are down this year 24.9 percent
of those dealers said they were down
compared with 25.3 percent who reported
their pre-sales are up compared with a
year ago on top of this less than six
percent of dealers surveyed said they
don't expect a price increase on new
equipment in 2013 but a big majority
86.4 percent believe price hikes for new
Machinery will range from one percent to
six percent
on a positive note more than 82 percent
of the dealers say that order
consolations were about at the same
level as they were last year with only
about 10 percent reporting cancel orders
were higher compared with 2011.
dealer comments were also telling about
how dealers felt about their business
prospects for 2013.
one Indiana dealer put it this way farm
income is such an unknown for 2013 and
I'm not sure where it will end up I've
given my answers to the survey but I'm
not confident they will be accurate As
Time plays out
I plan to be very cautious in ordering
in 2013 until I have a clear picture of
the conditions we will be dealing with
all of this is not to say that we're
looking at a difficult year in 2013.
what it does say is there seem to be
more unknowns this year than usual for
dealers to think about
also included with the October November
issue of the magazine is a complete
program for the upcoming dealership mine
Summit the first Conference of its kind
for dealers only it's going to happen at
the end of January 2013 in Kansas City
Missouri more than a dozen dealers from
our dealership of the Year alumni group
will be speaking on topics you'll want
to hear about check our website
www.farm Hyphen equipment.com for more
detail thanks for checking in and I'll
talk to you next time
foreign